here's more from justin james watt
on why he selected the arizona cardinals
and how much gas is left in that 32 year
old tank
the longer i looked at the more it just
signs kept pointing back down here you
know there's
there's a lot of exciting things about
what's happening down here in arizona
i've always said in this league you have
to have a quarterback to have a chance
and there's a
young extremely talented quarterback
here who can do big things and is going
from year two to year three and can take
an even bigger jump to continue to grow
and progress and
be even better then you've got i mean
you've got deandre hopkins who's one of
the best wide receivers in the league
i'm obviously very familiar with
you've got a defensive scheme and that's
led by vance joseph who i was with my
first three years down in houston
when underweight phillips and advance
runs a similar scheme to wade which is a
scheme i'm very familiar with and very
comfortable with
and excited to play in you've got guys
like chandler jones and buddha baker and
guys all over that defense that are
really
young excited guys ready to get after
ready to fly around and make some plays
so
i'm just very excited to be here and i'm
also not going to lie to you it doesn't
hurt when it's
65 degrees and sunny outside when i woke
up this morning so it's pretty nice
hey uh there's been so much talk uh
excitement in the valley about this but
also talk about how much
gas you have left at the tanks let us
ask how much gas do you feel like you
have left in the tank
a lot a whole lot
you know the last time he was that short
right with uh an interview question came
when john mcclane
asked him something about one of the
various games gone wrong for the texans
last year and
he was a little more perturbed then than
he was yesterday but you could tell
he didn't want to go down that path of
how much gas is in the tank
trust me it's a lot and he left it at
that
and and i don't doubt that there's gas
in the tank i just
from a dollars and cent standpoint
building a team allocating resources
how much do i trust that a guy who plays
a position where you're in that car
crash mode
every snap and you have made a career
out of it being
double-teamed and banged around and
injury after injury after injury i'm not
saying he's injury-prone i'm saying he's
incredibly brave and courageous
because he puts himself in those
positions where when you have that big
body that's being hit by other big
bodies you're
you're going to get injured that that's
a concern
that's a concern and that's what makes
it even more surprising that so much
money was invested by the cardinals
in justin james what well yeah yeah well
and you know you you talk about the car
crash stuff and all that like jj watt is
he's one of those defensive lineman that
throughout his whole career i mean it's
it's it's sell out it's pedal to the
metal and
when i say sell that i don't mean in a
bad way i mean he sells out and puts his
body on the line
every play you know he'll put his body
in you know compromising positions to
dive you know three gaps to the right to
try to make a tackle and a running back
or
you know he'll go full speed and try to
turn his body and split a double team
and sometimes get smashed
doing that you know that that's the one
he's not afraid to put himself in those
vulnerable positions
it's what made him great um now the the
thing about him and like yeah
your concerns and all that are real
there's no doubt about that
but here's like you know the other
aspect
you know not not to say he's like tom
brady exactly
but for a defensive lineman i mean he's
he's lives it he's been on his game his
whole career
it's he eats right he trains right
it's all year round it's never a thought
of like
oh i'm gonna take a bunch of time off i
mean he's always jacked he's always in
shape we see the workout sessions on
social media throughout the years and
all of that so
from that standpoint you know there is
good left in the tank
is it going to be the good we saw five
years ago where you just go oh my gosh
he's unblockable double teams you can't
even stop
him no but it's still really damn good
that he's gonna add value
to their defensive line for sure and i
think we talked about it a little
yesterday with just
other things that he brings to the table
that attitude you see right there the
professionalism
and of course the work ethic with the
young team that he mentioned is gonna
is gonna wear off on those guys yeah the
leadership the heart and soul of a
defense that really doesn't have that
one guy that stands out
as the clear leader of the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports